bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 8 juillet dernier jour du procès
de jacques crozemarie de 25 autres
personnes accusées de détournement de
fonds alors qu'ils étaient responsables
de l'arc l'association pour la recherche
contre le cancer en algérie deux mille
trois cents détenus sont concernés par
la grâce présidentielle sur la méthode
du nouveau chef de l'état sur ses
ambitions pour son pays
entretien exclusif avec monsieur
abdelaziz bouteflika président algérien
depuis alger qui suit des manifestations
anti milosevic en serbie au kosovo les
abonnés ont même fêté hier soir leur
liberté au conseil municipal de belgrade
affrontements avec les opposants de
milosevic à partir de demain à rouen le
plus important rassemblement navale de
la fin du siècle est offert la curiosité
publique parmi les voiliers de légende
le bel n
c'était aujourd'hui la fin du procès des
anciens responsables de l'arc
l'association pour la recherche contre
le cancer avec à leur tête jacques
crozemarie il risque cinq années de
prison ferme au maximum pour
détournement de fonds abus de confiance
et abus de biens sociaux mais les
avocats de jacques crozemarie ont voulu
dans leurs plaidoiries repousser toute
accusation pour rendre un hommage à
leurs clients reportage dominique
verdeilhan et andré y sera il y a le
jacques crozemarie d'aujourd'hui celui
qui évite les caméras tout au long de
son procès un immense voir est en train
de naître
et puis il y à celui d'hier celui qui
incarne la charity-business et la
recherche pour le cancer
c'est ce crozemarie là que défendent ses
avocats d'abord en contestant le pillage
de l'arc reprochés à leur client ensuite
en minimisant les chiffres de
l'accusation 20 millions de francs
détournés ces dix mètres mais ce nerf
0,3 pour cent du total des sommes
récoltées dans la même période
en face dit il il y a des milliers de
vies sauvées il a obtenu l'adhésion de
trois millions cinq cent mille personnes
il a obtenu plus de 6 milliards de
francs de dons qui ont été pour majeure
partie utilisent
et pour l'information pour la recherche
contre le cancer je ne pense pas qu'il
existe beaucoup de personnes en france
qui étaient autant vague rose marie
contre le cancer
un bilan médical et financier que ne
partage pas totalement l'actuel
président de l'arc c'est pas discutable
qu'il a fait beaucoup pour collecter des
fonds en faveur de la recherche mais je
constate qu'au cours de cette plaidoirie
on nous a dit tout ce qu'ils avaient été
collectés on a été beaucoup plus discret
sur l'importance des sommes
effectivement consacré à la recherche
jean marc varaut lui à un autre regard
sur jacques crozemarie médical toujours
mais cette fois c'est le client qui est
souffrant
il est victime dit-il d'amnésie et de
dégradation psychique
on l'aura compris m e varaut plaide les
circonstances atténuantes pour éviter à
jacques crozemarie un retour en prison
alors dominique verdeilhan quel est le
bilan judiciaire de ces longues semaines
de ce procès écoutez on peut parler
évidemment d'un procès nécessaire mais
également un procédé rothan parce que
comme dans tout scandale financier
on ne peut pas ne pas avoir le vertige
or les sommes évoquées à l'audience 585
millions de francs dans la caisse de
l'arc en 96 300 millions de francs
détournés puis ce qui est choquant dans
cette affaire dans ce procès c'est qu'il
a été fusillé question des travaux de la
piscine de la villa de bandol de jacques
crozemarie que de la recherche
proprement dit parce que le procès de
jacques crozemarie c'est aussi le procès
de certaines absences absence à la barre
par exemple des chercheurs des
cancérologues absences également des
donateurs certes l'arc l'association est
aujourd'hui partie civile mais c'est un
procès sans victime déshumanisé j'allais
dire sans âme
conséquence les avocats de jacques
crozemarie et bien ont tenté cet
après-midi d'occuper ce créneau celui de
la victime
réponse avec le jugement le 19 octobre
merci dominique concernant la demande en
révision de la condamnation du
vétérinaire jean louis turquin condamné
en 97 20 ans de prison pour le meurtre
de son fils une nouvelle enquête vient
d'être ordonné pour établir s'il ya bien
un élément nouveau permettant la
révision du procès il faut rappeler que
selon certains témoignages le fils de
monsieur dure 15 serait bien vivant mais
retenu actuellement dans une communauté
en israël
y at il un lien entre des cas de
leucémie signalé dans la population de
la région de lag et les activités de
l'établissement nucléaire le groupe de
travail mis en place par les ministres
de l'environnement et de la santé pour
donner un avis n'a pas réussi à se
mettre d'accord il est vrai qu'il
contient à la fois des écolos et des
scientifiques dans doute on s'abstient
donc de désigner la plus grande usine au
monde de retraitement des déchets
nucléaires comme responsable
reportage hélène béring claude bernier
et andrei sera voici le rapport tant
attendu le texte censé mettre fin aux
polémiques soulevées par les études du
professeur viel
ce médecin avait mis en évidence un
excès de cas de leucémie à proximité de
l'usiné de la hague
aujourd'hui après deux années d enquête
les résultats peuvent paraître rassure
je n'ai pas réussi à montrer qu'il y a
un rapport entre le niveau de
radioactivité que l'on trouve dans la
mer ou que l'on trouve dans les poissons
et les cas de leucémie qui sont observés
selon le rapport la proportion de
leucémie attribuable à l'industrie
nucléaire dans le nord cotentin serait
de 0,2 pour cent le reste proviendrait
de sources d'exposition différentes
médical et surtout naturels issus par
exemple du sol
au total cinq cent mille mesures
réalisées dans la région comme ici près
de lusine cogema ont été vérifiés validé
par l'ensemble des experts si les
chiffres ne sont pas contestées leurs
interprétations rassurantes ne fait pas
l'unanimité les cas de leucémie observés
ne peuvent pas être expliquées par serge
est reconstituée et à l'aide de ses
modèles donc moi je lui on serait en
disant que dans le cadre des projets
réels
eh bien il reste de l'argent
incertitudes on saura exactement comment
ils passent dans l'environnement et
comment on peut faire des doses et que
dans ces conditions je recommanderais la
plus grande prudence
c'est à dire limiter les rejets dans
l'environnement et compléter les
recherches incertitude ou pas la cogema
est satisfaite aujourd'hui un premier
travail scientifique est achevée les
ministres devront dire si le risque lié
à l'industrie nucléaire est acceptable
en algérie ce sont finalement deux mille
trois cents détenus islamistes qui
seront libérés grâce à la décision du
président d'ela this bouteflika celui ci
a exclu les auteurs de crimes de sang de
sa décision de grâce dans quelques
instants nous entendrons le président
algérien
mais aujourd'hui les familles des
victimes des actions terroristes
manifesté dans la capitale algérienne
faisant part de leurs craintes que l'on
efface trop rapidement par ses grâces
cent mille victimes d'une véritable
guerre civile qui aura duré neuf ans
reportage eric monier christian hottin
c'est l'espoir qui les a menés là espoir
de voir un fils un frère militants
islamistes profité de l'amnistié libéré
aujourd'hui peut-être ou bien demain de
cette prison d'el harrach délibération
jusqu'ici au compte gouttes
elle n'est même pas sûr que son fils
unique soit prisonnier dans la lettre
qu'elle exhibe elle réclame aux
autorités des nouvelles un signe de vie
comme elle le dit sans réponse depuis
bientôt noël vient de passer six ans
dans cette prison elle et son mari
militaire pour l'ex office il a été tué
elle est l'une des premières à avoir été
libérée il ya trois jours
nerveuse elle accepte cependant de nous
parler
si je suis revenu c'est parce que
j'attends mes amis dit-elle il ya encore
une cinquantaine de filles là dedans
certaines sont emprisonnés seulement
parce qu elles sont soeurs ou femmes de
terroristes
nawel n'en dira pas plus
son frère lui conseille de se taire et
les lois au même moment dans le centre
d'alger 200 manifestants s'opposent à
ces amnesty
la police leur interdit l'accès au
parlement voulons vote aujourd'hui un
soutien à la politique du président
bouteflika
tous ont perdu un proche dans un
attentat terroriste
ils dénoncent l'impunité l'injustice
depuis c'est un caporal-chef du trou
plus tard de la marée il a été égorgé il
décapite égide jésus devant six mois
puis moi j'ai du mal à 6 moi et ma
famille et maintenant ils vont va
également donné droit aux avalats il ne
nous apprend rien entendre les partis
politiques d'opposition eux sont dans
l'expectative sans vouloir cautionner la
politique présidentielle que beaucoup
jugent comme un cadeau aux terroristes
pas question néanmoins d'apparaître
comme des opposants à la paix le
président bouteflika nous a accordé un
entretien que nous avons enregistrées
dans le courant de cet après-midi en
duplex d'alger du palais présidentiel
première question monsieur bouteflika
elle concerne son choix d'user du
référendum pour obtenir un assentiment
populaire dans ses décisions marquant
son souhait d'une concorde nationale
bouteflika il n'y a aucune réticence au
niveau de l'armée mais j'ai besoin du
soutien populaire pour avancer il est
tout à fait clair que nous sommes dans
une expérience démocratique nous a fait
naissante et que les voix ne sont pas
unanimes pour telle ou telle autre
démarche qui dit démocratie dit le
principe du gouvernement avec la
majorité
il est tout à fait clair que une telle
monsieur de par sa dimension et son
caractère historique me paraissent me
paraît en tout cas appelé un suffrage
populaire
une jeune je dois avoir l'aval populaire
pour prendre les décisions adéquates
je considère que chaque goutte
algérienne de sang à son prix et il est
tout à fait clair que je ferai tout ce
qui est en mon pouvoir de faire pour
arrêter cette tragédie pour faire la
paix monsieur le président il faut il
vendre négocier avec son adversaire
est ce que vous êtes prêt à engager des
discussions des entretiens avec des
représentants du gia par exemple
monsieur je ne la république négocie
avec personne la république est là à
pâtir d'une constitution à partir
d'institutions à partir de lois
républicaines qui essaie d'offrir des
solutions à ceux qui pour une raison ou
une autre et peut avoir des raisons
objectives aux demeures se sont laissés
entraîner vers un phénomène d'expression
par la violence je crois avoir ouvert le
champ ou si vaste que je peux le faire
dans le cadre de mes attributions en
tant que magistrat numéro un du pays
pour permettre aussi bien aux uns et aux
autres de le joindre le bercail sans
perdre la face
alors concernant la politique que vous
entendez mené en algérie vous avez
annoncé une lutte contre la corruption
ça veut dire quoi concrètement à mon
cher ami je voudrais vous dire une chose
c'est que je trouve une situation où il
ya très peu de choses qui ne sont pas
tout à fait comme on peut alors pas quoi
commencer je pense que
sur le plan national il ya un certain
nombre de mesures qui me paraissent
inévitables c'est la mort dans l'âme que
je le fais mais je le ferai mais je
militerai sur le plan international pour
une convention internationale de lutte
contre la corruption dans le monde
c'est un fléau absolument terrible et
qui ne permettra jamais aux pays du
tiers-monde de décoller si cette
situation devait continuer la population
algérienne est très jeune n'y ait
beaucoup de jeunes femmes notamment
beaucoup d'entre elles s'inquiètent du
code de la famille du statut de la femme
avez vous l'intention de réformer ce
code voire de l'abroger
tout ce qui est en mon pouvoir de faire
je le ferai je ne porterai jamais jamais
jamais un verset coranique raconte j'ai
la conviction profonde que le problème
n'est pas au niveau de la fois où des
versets coraniques
le problème est au niveau de la
calcification de certains esprits et
principalement de d'une population
algérienne qui n'a pas compris que les
52% de la population
c'est des femmes
c'est une démarche pédagogique qui
demandera un peu de temps je la ferai
c'est un pari qui ne fait pas peur
de toutes les façons je n'aurai pas peur
ces comptes de pouce on sait déjà une
majorité pour gouverner un pays
alors vous avez des liens personnels je
crois très anciens avec le président
chirac
qu'est ce que vous attendez directement
de lui vous avez montré un petit
agacement juste après votre élection en
disant que les français devait un peu se
mêler de leurs affaires mais qu'ils
devaient montrer très directement leur
attachement avec l'algérie non je n'ai
pas montré d'agacement je suis là comme
le président chirac est chargé de
défendre les intérêts supérieurs de son
pays et la france et c'est son droit et
son devoir je suis là aussi pour
défendre les intérêts supérieurs de mon
pays et c'est aussi mon droit et mon
devoir
si je le fais à ma manière je ne suis ni
content ni agacé je le fais à ma manière
c'est simplement une question de style
de formulation peut-être que la langue
française n'étant pas ma langue
maternelle je la manipule de façon
suffisamment compréhensibles pour mes
interlocuteurs mais je dis très
sincèrement ce que je pense du fond du
coeur avec un coeur immense immense
immense et qui peut contenir toute la
france y compris bien entendu mon ami le
président chirac et ont vaincu les
françaises je remercie monsieur le
président nous avons accordé cet
entretien merci beaucoup
alors entretien enregistré donc cet
après midi préparé par thierry thulliez
a paris eric maudier alger à belgrade
lors du conseil municipal un
représentant de l'opposition a pris la
parole pour demander la démission de
milosevic qui a provoqué vous allez le
voir une belle pagaille beaucoup de
bruit et de bouard même à belgrade ont
petit à petit des opposants et des
habitants commencent à se faire entendre
mais l'événement de cette journée fut la
venue d'une délégation d'opposants ce
cow boys and girls beach au kosovo cette
délégation conduite par l'ancien maire
de belgrade zoran djindjic
l'objectif de celui ci étant de rendre
possible retour des serbes au kosovo en
souhaitant toujours le départ de scott
dann milosevic au portage agnès
vahramian et nathalie gallet en terre
que ce bar the rise and each est venu
prêcher la réconciliation avec les
albanais et demandé aux serbes de rester
vivre ici l'opposant à slobodan
milosevic a choisi pour cette visite
l'unique eu lieu serbe où l'on partage
ses idées et où sa sécurité d'assurer le
monastère de crachats nizza en effet
c'est pop ont demandé dès la semaine
dernière la démission de slobodan
milosevic comme opposants au chef de
l'état serbe zoran dit nietzsche a donc
tout intérêt à s'afficher aux côtés des
religieux à la sortie se sont d'ailleurs
mais pop
il tente de calmer la foule ces
villageois qui l'insultent reprochent au
leader du parti démocrate devenir trop
tard de s'être réfugié au monténégro
pendant les bombardements de l'otan de
vouloir vendre le kosovo dinkic il cet
homme on n'a pas besoin de lui on n'est
pas des enfants c'est un mauvais
dirigeants les partisans de ce modèle
milosevic pudding beach dehors et les
hervé par la présence de journalistes
occidentaux
mais parmi ces villageois sunnites
j'avais ses partisans plus discret
les idées de jean dit 'je sont bonnes
mais lodevic doit partir la moitié du
peuple est d'accord mais personne n'ose
le dire ce soir zoran djindjic prenait
la tête d'une nouvelle manifestation de
l'opposition en serbie il tire ainsi un
bénéfice immédiat de sa visite ici en
démontrant à ceux qui en doutaient qu'il
reste attaché un kosovo lie à la
fédération yougoslave
et lors de cette manifestation devienne
pas renier sera mieux en pro culié c'est
dans le sud de la serbie sur un dj a
demandé un référendum pour ou contre le
départ de slobodan milosevic
aux etats unis c'est confirmait hillary
clinton se lance dans la politique elle
sera candidate pour un poste de sénateur
de new york et tant pis pour ceux qui
déjà dénonce une certaine confusion
entre son rôle de première dame
américaine et celui de militantes
politiques désireuses d'être élu au
sénat
reportage de niedernai officiellement
elle n'est pas encore candidate au poste
de sénateur elle y réfléchit c'est tout
les élections ne sont que dans 16 mois
rien ne presse et si trois jours durant
elle m'a la campagne s'est dit elle pour
aller à la rencontre des habitants de
l'état de new york
les écouter mais pour la presse
américaine qui se bousculent sur son
passage cela ne fait plus aucun doute
hillary clinton sera bien la première
épouse d'un président des états unis à
se lancer dans une bataille électorale
j'imagine que vous vous demandez tout ce
pour quoi le sénat pourquoi new york et
pourquoi moi
à ces questions pourtant elle se gardera
bien de répondre se bornant à répéter
qu'il vaudrait mieux s'intéresser aux
idées auxquelles des
plutôt qu'à son lieu de naissance ses
détracteurs les républicains partisans
de rudi giuliani le maire de new york ne
se prive pas en effet de dénoncer ce
parachutage dans un état où hillary
clinton originaire de chicago n'a ni
grandit ni vécu où elle ne figure même
pas encore sur les listes d'électeurs et
puis 17 femmes
on ne veut pas de ces idées en matière
d'éducation on n'est pas d'accord avec
elle sur l'avortement
sans parler de tous ces scandales liés à
ce gouvernement totalement coraux et
elle voudrait qu'on hérite de tout ça et
de bill clinton par dessus le marché
non merci
les sondages pour l'instant la dette au
coude à coude avec un rudi giuliani qui
lui non plus ne s'est pas encore déclaré
candidat
si dans la métropole hillary clinton
peut espérer faire un bon score
l'arrière pays est traditionnellement un
fief conservateur en tant que première
dame des etats-unis elle a su insuffler
à la maison blanche son énergie elle
connaît par coeur tous les états de
l'union elle est brillant cultivé le
reste n'a aucune importance
pendant un quart de siècle elle s'est
consacrée à la carrière de son mari
désormais c'est seul qu'il a ri part à
la conquête du pouvoir
d'ailleurs pas une seule fois au cours
de cette journée
elle n'aura prononcer le nom de bill
clinton apparition exceptionnelle du
dictateur nord coréen kim jong il
le fils de kim il sung était en public à
pyonyang pour le 5e anniversaire de la
mort de son père mais il n'est pas
intervenu n'ait pas pris la parole
devant cette immense foule recueillie
pour l'anniversaire de la mort du père
de kim jong il kim il sung
et puis en arménie des obsèques à une
vingtaine de kilomètres de la capitale
erevan du chef de l'église arménienne
le catholicos karekin premier plusieurs
milliers d'arméniens assistaient à la
cérémonie
karim premier était âgé de 66 ans est
décédée d'un cancer il avait pris la
direction de l'église arménienne en 95
c'est à dire quatre ans après
l'accession de son pays à l'indépendance
l'industrie américaine du tabac vient de
connaître un nouvel échec un juge de
miami désignant les grands cigarettiers
comme responsables des morts par le
cancer estime à plusieurs centaines de
milliards de dollars
les indemnités qui devront verser en
réparation commentaires maryse burgot
l'un de leurs proches est mort du cancer
après avoir fumé pendant de longues
années pendant de longues années ces
américains ont donc lutter devant les
tribunaux contre l'industrie du tabac
alors aujourd'hui c'est dont les larmes
qu'ils apprécient leur victoire
judiciaire sans précédent dans ce
tribunal de floride 5 grands
cigarettiers vient d'être reconnue
responsable de nombreuses maladies dont
plusieurs types de cancer question
numéro 1 est ce que fumer des cigarettes
provoque une ou plusieurs des maladies
suivantes anévrismes ah oui le juge
ajoute que les fabricants ont vendu des
cigarettes avec l'intention d'infliger
un préjudice grave c'est la première
fois qu'une plainte collective
réunissant plusieurs familles de
victimes abouti après des mois de
délibérations les dommages et intérêts
versés par les fabricants de cigarettes
pourrait atteindre 3000 milliards de
francs presque deux fois le budget de la
france
alors bien sûr les cinq grands groupes
vont faire appel dans les précédents
procès qui ne concernait que des
plaintes individuelles
ils ont souvent réussi à faire minorer
leur condamnation en deuxième instance
mais cette fois ils doivent s'attendre à
une avalanche de plaintes de familles de
fumeurs une aubaine pour les cabinets
d'avocats et un cauchemar pour les
cigarettiers qui ont pourtant tenté de
faire diminuer le nombre de procès en
négociant directement avec l'état
américain
les premières cotations en france des
actions du crédit lyonnais ont été
couronnés de succès l'action était en
hausse de plus de 21% à 3 millions 400
mille particuliers ont demandé des
actions du crédit lyonnais privatiser la
commission nationale informatique et
libertés la cnil vient de rendre public
son rapport d'activité une large part de
ce rapport évoque les systèmes
d'interconnexion informatique c'est à
dire concrètement pour le particulier
une sorte de gigantesque toile
d'araignée de moyens de surveillance et
de contrôle potentiel ce qui pourrait
menacer les libertés individuelles
une équipe de france 2 avec marc
maisonneuve est évidemment à choisi pour
commencer son reportage la commune de
levallois près de paris
pour illustrer cette situation à
levallois il ya le plus grand nom
deux caméras de surveillance et les
croisements de toutes les données en
images ou en codes peuvent théoriquement
permettre de connaître tout de la vie de
tout le monde
où que vous alliez où vous regarde à
levallois-perret la ville fleurie
proclament les panneaux pourtant il n'y
a guère que les caméras qui fleurissent
ici elles sont partout avec un seul
objectif la vidéosurveillance près des
commerçants des carrefours 1600 au total
claude fournier vite à levallois depuis
35 ans il est parti en vacances laissant
son immeuble sans surveillance à son
retour une caméra était implanté sur la
façade sans explication monsieur fourni
vis cela comme une agression et devrait
à cette situation de la loi changeront
de sa duc 2 / fax aux problèmes restés
en bêta le maire de levallois et les
membres de son cabinet ont refusé de
nous rencontrer
ici on filme on ne parle pas peut-être
n'habitez vous pas elle valoir
mais si vous avez un portable ou une
carte bancaire vous êtes vous aussi sous
haute surveillance et cela 24 heures sur
chez les informaticiens la trace de
l'activité des puces figure sur ce
qu'ils appellent des journaux des
relevés informatiques qui peuvent
permettre de suivre votre piste
y'a pas forcément un traitement
automatique un traitement systématique
ces journaux mais qu'en fonction des
besoins on peut repartir de journaux
d'historique d'activité pour pouvoir
reconstituer la vie des communications
la vie économique d'une carte bleue une
carte bancaire pardon et la vie tout
court d'un individu à la préfecture de
police la vie de paris est analysée sous
contrôle cette intrusion permanente dans
la vie privée inquiète les défenseurs
des libertés individuelles
il faut que la police ce qui quand elle
détient un fichier informatique est une
arme considérable il faut qu'elles
soient formés au rester des citoyens
développement du sens civique pour ne
pas abuser du droit qu'elle a et qu'elle
sache exactement la qualité de larmes
qu'elle rentre éléments de la sécurité
sociale au numéro dean c'est notre vie
entière et contenues dans des
ordinateurs
il y en france aujourd'hui près de 3
millions de fichiers nominatifs et tous
différents
la france a décidé de proposer aux deux
postes de commissaires européens qui lui
reviennent monsieur michel barnier
ancien mise de l'environnement et des
affaires européennes et sénateur de la
savoie monsieur barnier avait également
conduit avec jean claude killy
l'organisation des jeux olympiques
d'albertville et puis pour l'autre poste
de commissaire européen outre monsieur
barnier c'est pascal lamy qui a été
désigné pascal lamy fut le directeur de
cabinet de jacques delors lorsque celui
ci présidait la commission européenne il
était jusqu'à présent de la direction
générale du crédit lyonnais
enfin daniel cohn bendit a décidé de
demander la nationalité française amusé
par les spéculations politiques de
postes possibles qu'on lui prête
il veut at il dit dans un sourire leur
donner maintenant une base juridique
mise en examen pour abus de confiance de
l'ancien ministre gaulliste et ancien
président de la région des pays de loire
monsieur olivier guichard les faits qui
lui sont reprochés auraient été commis
alors qu'il présidait ce conseil
et ce jusqu'en 1998 le juge
d'instruction chargé de l'affairé des
paillotes incendies en corse a bien lu
la lettre que lui a adressée le préfet
bernard bonnet maître dans laquelle
celui ci mettait en cause des
conseillers du premier ministre et le
juge d'instruction a décidé de convoquer
pour demain à ajaccio la collaboratrice
de monsieur jospin madame clotilde
valter
c'est un progrès exceptionnels pour les
personnes handicapées un progrès qui
pour l'instant bénéficié un champion
sportif celui ci est amputé il s'appelle
dominique andrey il est champion de
france handisport du 100 et du 200 m et
ses performances ne sont pas très
éloignés des champions valide il
bénéficie en effet de ce que l'on
appelle un pied dynamique restituant une
énergie spectaculaire et fabriqué par
des orthoprothésiste de montpellier vous
voyez le reportage de véronique gaglione
et françoise maso le sport on lui avait
dit qu'il n'en ferai jamais plus comme
avant
il avait 14 ans et un chauffeur venait
de lui arraché la jambe
depuis dominique andré ne quitte plus la
piste champion de france 100 et 200 m
champion d'europe handisport en 97
aujourd'hui quand ils courent ils
oublient enfin la prothèse moi j'ai
toujours fait du sport dont mon père m'a
poussée de suite à faire du vélo à
refaire un peu de sport je fais du
tennis tout ça mais avec beaucoup de
souffrance et ne pouvant pas pratique
est souvent parce que justement beaucoup
de souffrance et donc ça a évolué
jusqu'à maintenant des prothèses que qui
sont une très inconfortable performante
et la maintenance et le physique qui
suit plus la prothèse toujours bien le
pied de course a été mise au point par
un prothésiste de montpellier avec des
matériaux capables de restituer
l'énergie de chaque foulée en la matière
c'est tout est matière à miss est une
fibre composite vers air très a trait
aux modules donnant un module
d'élasticité et de rang boit beaucoup
plus élevé que vers fibre de carbone
le constater que ce morceau était
nettement moindre avec une rue sur un
renvoi beaucoup plus importants auteurs
souffler ce alignement rien n'est laissé
au hasard pour la prothèse de dominique
et c'est toute une technologie qui
s'affine au cours des mois et qui fini
par bénéficier à tous les amputés ceux
qui ne font pas de sport de haut niveau
bien sûr le pied montpelliérain prend
alors une forme plus classique on
l'habille on peut le maquiller à la
perfection il devient un produit tout à
fait concurrentiel sur un marché dominé
à 80% par les amériques
la technologie va tellement en avant que
ce n'est plus le bout de bois qui est
posée sur notre bout de bois si des
matériaux qui sont vivaces nos matériaux
actifs
un jour peut-être un an vite et
rivalisera avec un champion valide
dominique andré court le 100 m en 12
secondes on s'en tienne sa foulée
pourrait le mener jusqu'aux jeux
olympiques de sydney je vais vous
signaler deux jours de solidarité en
faveur de la lutte contre le sida ces
samedi et dimanche c'est sur
l'hippodrome de longchamp à paris le
festival solidays avec plusieurs
concerts de jour et de nuit du sport du
cyclisme tour de france que l'arrivée de
la 5e étape à amiens fut la copie
conforme à celle d'hier à blois
vous l'avez vu rapidement mais elle
revoir bien c'est l'italien ciccolini
qui a remporté sa deuxième victoire
d'affilée au sprint et l'estonien quercy
ku qui conserve le maillot jaune
et puis si vous voulez connaître toutes
les infos sur le déroulement des états
je vous invite à noter le site internet
de france 2 qui s'affiche en ce moment
sur votre écran et lors du générique en
athlétisme un nouveau record du monde
sur la licence du mil records du monde
battus par le marocain hicham el
guerrouj
voici les images de l'arrivée de ce
mille avec le record du monde 3 minutes
43 secondes et 13 centièmes record
établi hier à rome
ce sera le plus grand rassemblement de
voiliers de la fin du siècle à partir de
demain jusqu'au 18 juillet à rouen une
trentaine de voiliers de légende vont
former une gigantesque armada avec
quelques milliers de marins représentant
une trentaine de nations parmi ces
voiliers
le belem à l'origine
à la fin du 19e siècle qui transportait
du cacao du brésil jusqu'à nantes depuis
1979 c'est l'association pour la
sauvegarde et la conservation des
anciens navires français qui lui a
redonné vie et puis sur le belem
on peut apprendre toutes les techniques
traditionnelles de la marine à voile
reportage fanni au vernis et delphine
detry embarquement pour une croisière
sans piscine sans cabine luxueuse sans
transat sans repos ici il n'ya pas de
passagers tous sont membres d'équipage
sont les mêmes depuis plus d'un siècle
construit en 1896 le belem est le
dernier trois mâts français à voiles
carrées encore en activité une sorte de
fantôme des mères dont la silhouette
fait revivre l'élégance des antiques
caravelle à bord on y apprend le
matelotage c'est à dire de vivre un peu
comme un matelot pour l'instant c'est
vrai qu'on n'a pas encore commencé les
quarts mais
va le faire et si
oui c'est d'être des principes eux de
vivre la vie des gens comme ça comme ça
se passe à embarquer sur un tel bateau
la plupart d'entre eux en rêvait depuis
longtemps
quarante ans pour caubère par exemple il
espérait faire carrière dans la marine
avant de devenir instituteur aujourd'hui
il réalise enfin son voeu le plus cher
j'aurais peur d'aller sur un bateau où
ce serait trop installé on navigue là
dans un bateau cassant temps et c'est
bien votre commande à mon sens et
cherche pas le luxe je ne cherche pas
laventure cherche quelque chose de vrai
et le belem est pas encore très vrai
vrai comme la rigueur de la vie à bord
prendre le car de jour comme de nuit
faire la vaisselle astiquer les cuivres
rien ne leur est épargné
on va
malartic au plus court entre de
manoeuvre pour les plus vaillants
il y a encore le cours théorique mais
parcours temps pour une bonne moitié de
ses marins improvisé aventure tourne
court
au salon sur le pont à l'air frais et on
attend que ça passe
tu quand même souffert deux jours pour
le reprenne est le fondement des temps
les jours de votre forme tout allait
bien voilà c'est pour ça que je vous
dise si j'ai peut-être qu'ils vont faire
un autre mais pas immédiatement il
faudra le temps de digérer ce coup là et
puis enfin après quatre jours à bord les
goélands annonce la bonne nouvelle la
terre toutes proches les familles
retrouvent leur apprendre ce marin pour
certains c'est juré jamais plus ils le
remettront les pieds sur le pont d'un
bateau mais il y a les mordus de la
voile carrée qui en sont déjà à leur 20e
course en auvergne aussi curieux que
cela puisse paraître les volcans
seraient des propriétés privées ce qui
entraîne quelques débats juridiques sur
le droit à l'image puisque les
propriétaires de ces volcans réclame
maintenant de l'argent dès lors que l'on
utilise leurs sites magnifiques à des
fins publicitaires
reportage stéphane haumant marie leurs
jambes les volcans d'auvergne sont beaux
et photogénique
si photogénique que toutes les marques
de la région utilisent leur image
ce qu'on sait moins c'est que les
volcans d'auvergne sont aussi des
propriétés privées 350 particuliers
possèdent des parcelles sur les plus
beaux massifs et aujourd'hui il réclame
des royalties aux publicitaires
lorsque notre patrimoine et notre shit
est employé à des fins commerciales
notamment par de grosses firmes et bien
nous nous estimons propriétaire que nous
devons quand même en avoir quelques
retombées
première cible le géant casino de
clermont ferrand l'hypermarché a
organisé en mars dernier une quinzaine
gastronomique la fiche montrait le
cratère du pariot les propriétaires
réclament donc 120 mille francs de
droits mais le magasin refuse de payer
l'image d'un volcan patrimoine naturel
de la région
je suis moi-même originaire d'auvergne
et deux tiers et le poirier au bon j'ai
vécu à son pied je les ai vus dans les
manuels scolaires
j'étais très très surpris lorsque en
effet
j'appris d'abord c'était vous voyez
était privée et que je porterai une
atteinte
l'utilisation de l'image ici les photos
des volcans sont partout c'est la
première fois que des clichés d'un
paysage pourrait être poursuivi en
justice pour les professionnels de la
communication et du tourisme donné
raison au propriétaire serait une
absurdité
il n'y a plus une seule carte postale
qui est possible à partir du moment où
quelqu'un reconnaîtrait sa maison on
reconnaîtrait sur toi et puis ça réclame
n'est un droit quelconque sur cette
image après le tournage de sa dernière
campagne
volvic a versé environ 100 mille francs
le bleu d'auvergne négocier à son tour
un accord
les gentils volcan pourrait bientôt
devenir un méchant gouffre financier
rétrospective au musée maillol à paris
des oeuvres du peintre américain keith
haring il fut très symbolique des
artistes des années 80 peignant un peu
partout sur des objets sur des murs neuf
ans après sa mort cette rétrospective
nous permet de retrouver les silhouettes
et les personnages de caisse haring
retrouvailles dans le métro reportage
daniel wolfromm et jean-paul chaussée
de drôles de diable avec leur nez rouge
presque des tags ou des graffitis keith
haring représentait bien sa génération
les enfants naturels des artistes du pop
art comme eux ils devraient loin des
lieux habituels de la culture au ras du
bitume et du métro tout est parti entre
1980 et 1982 par exemple il a fait plus
de 3000 des stands le lieu même du
groupe
placards publicitaires tout le film a du
métro c'est le lieu s'il aspire qui vous
donne envie de créer un art destinée à
tous peu après ses premiers dessins à la
craie dans le métro keith haring exposé
dans les galeries de new york le succès
est fulgurant
la reconnaissance internationale il
peint partout des fresques en plein air
à paris aussi comme à l'hôpital des
enfants malades
mais depuis son travail s'est fondu dans
la grisaille
c'est un artiste américain c'est
possible oui ou non j'ai pas équipé vous
aviez remarqué déjà qui avait une oeuvre
derrière vous ruine on est sifflé depuis
disons qu'on puisse nous y avait déjà
quelques années on l'a vu faire mais
qu'il a fait je sais pas il est donc pas
inutile de se rafraîchir la mémoire le
musée maillol présente une série de
travaux de keith haring liés à ces
séjours en france à l'image de ce fameux
diable pas pour les 10 ans de beaubourg
qui sert elle ne fait jamais un dessin
préparatoire jamais toute son oeuvre est
une spontanéité total même l'oeuvre
défis nés et tout est à main levée c'est
dans la grande tradition japonaise c'est
à dire pas trop sentir fait presque zen
il dessine les rites ablement la main et
la continuité de la pensée mais keith
haring est atteint du sida et meurt à 32
ans le 16 février 1990 à new york
et c'est au musée maillol nous arrivons
à la fin du journal je vous rappelle
l'information concernant la fin du
procès des responsables de l'arc
poursuivi pour détournement de fonds
le jugement concernant jacques
crozemarie les 25 autres personnes
accusées sera rendu le 19 octobre
prochain
dans un instant la météo patrice drevet
suivi du point route de valérie maurice
et puis je vous recommande spécialement
les nouveaux mondes ensuite le magazine
de découverte scientifique présentée par
antoine de maximy que vous retrouverez
tous les jeudis pendant cet été sur
france 2 ce soir vous aurez droit
notamment une découverte à bornéo avec
les orangs outans c'est dans quelques
minutes
à 23h20 la 25e heure de jacques perrin
sera consacrée à nelson mandela demain
7h 50 dans les 4 vérités françoise
laborde recevra la mema bonino la
commissaire italienne osaka l'action
humanitaire à 13h retrouverez carole
gaessler ici et rachid arhab sur la
route du tour
et à 20h béatrice schönberg bonnes
vacances à ceux qui partent à lundi
bonsoir merci
le tout